the essential feeling of the movie
aliens is that everything
is falling apart that's exactly what
aliens fire team elite is going for
you start out a confident marine as you
head into a xenomorph-infested facility
but slowly you find yourself more and
more overwhelmed
as you fight through swarms of aliens as
ammo and medpax deplete at key moments
you start to get a bit worried then at
the end of the mission
you're stuck standing in front of an
elevator knowing that as soon as you hit
the button to call it and make your
escape the aliens
will come for you even with full ammo
and defensive tools like sentry guns and
mines
you're about to be in a fight for your
life
it's this aspect of aliens the 1986
james cameron movie
that most games based on the film
struggle to capture
or miss altogether in the movie the
colonial marines
lose they spend most of their time
getting picked off
trying to defend against overwhelming
odds and running for their lives
in the eight or so hours of aliens fire
team elite we played in a preview build
the game did a pretty good job of
distilling that sensation
into a cooperative third person shooter
no matter how well equipped you are
you're going to find yourself starting
to sweat
as threats close in from all sides you
create your own marine in fire team
elite and join a team of up to two
other players or ai bots if you want to
play alone
dispatched to investigate a weyland
yutani mining operation that has gone
dark
at launch the game takes place over 4 3
chapter campaigns
with each chapter lasting around 20 to
25 minutes
the overall feel of fire team elite is
similar to left for dead
with you and your teammates moving
through an area and trying to accomplish
objectives while constantly being
attacked by waves of enemies
our preview gave us a glimpse at the
first two campaigns of the game
as you discover in the first campaign
the faceless but always evil
weyland-yutani corporation
has uncovered something on the surface
of planet lv895
and they've used it to start some pretty
dumb sounding experiments
to mutate xenomorphs that quickly
creates a situation
in which you see a mess of new kinds of
aliens that haven't appeared
in the films before
team elite quickly throws creatures at
you that will spit acid from a distance
rush forward to explode or hide on
ceilings and in corners
to leap out and pin you to the ground
the game also adds in some of the
tougher variations from other games and
movies
like the human-like drone from alien
isolation or the deadly warrior from
aliens
it all means you have a variety of
creatures that require you to quickly
change your
focus as a team to put down the most
pressing threats
all while the room fills with more and
more sleek
monsters you do have plenty of ways to
fight back though
iconic aliens weapons like the pulse
rifle smart
gun flamethrower and pump action shotgun
are at your disposal
your loadout in a given mission is
determined by the class you choose at
its start
garners will remind you of rank and file
marines like hicks
with their pulse rifles and backup
shotguns demolishers carry smart guns
that can rip through hordes quickly
technicians rely on close quarters
weapons but carry a sentry gun that they
can deploy over and over again
and docks get a pulse rifle but give up
a stronger secondary weapon
in favor of a deployable item that can
heal teammates
each class is unique in ways that allow
you to coordinate with your team
they all have different abilities that
have cooldown timers which can buff the
entire team at key moments
gunners can make everyone fire and
reload their guns more quickly
while demolishers can damage lots of
enemies at once while gaining a damage
boost
the technician's sentry guns convey a
defense buff to anyone nearby
and docks can boost everyone's reload
and movement speeds
there are also a host of consumables
that you can buy between missions or
find in crates at key moments
which give you tactical options for
defending positions with special types
of
ammo as well as the aforementioned mines
and turrets
the further we got into fire team elite
the more our squad had to work together
to find the best strategies to survive
the first campaign sends you to an
orbital refinery called katanga
in search of a survivor and it's not
unlike the refinery towed by the
nostromo
in the 1979 film alien it's also
absolutely overrun with xenomorphs
thanks to weyland yutani meddling
by the end of the campaign you're
escorting the survivor out
working to keep him alive along with the
rest of your team
as you run for a dropship under constant
alien threat
in the second campaign you head down to
the planet's surface where you start to
uncover what the company has
found here fire team elite starts to
bridge with the newer alien films
prometheus and alien covenant as you
explore vast caverns created by
prometheus's progenitor race
the white-skinned engineers
weyland-yutani gets serious
about protecting what it has found there
and in the second campaign
a variety of synthetic soldiers join the
fray alongside the aliens
these include gun-wielding combat synths
and engineering-focused working joes of
alien isolation
illustrating the ways that fireteam
elite is drawing from all corners of the
franchise
to fill out its world in these missions
combat changes
significantly you'll usually either
stand your ground or
constantly relocate to fight the mostly
close range aliens
but the synth soldiers carry guns which
turns fire team elite into a cover
shooter
but the game also mixes these threats
together and even has the aliens
fighting the synths so your strategy has
to constantly change
based on what's trying to kill you and
if you're smart
you'll find ways to let your enemies
kill each other
it's clear throughout fireteam elite
that developer cold iron studio has a
full command
of the alien universe and its
combination of elements makes the world
of the colonial marines
feel much more fleshed out collectible
lore items you can find
fill in background elements like the
political situation between the marines
government
the united americas and corporations
like weyland yutani
they also bring in deep cuts from the
franchise lower
such as the union of progressive peoples
the soviet block successor faction
that first appeared in author william
gibson's unproduced alien 3 screenplay
it also seems like there's a lot more
going on with the inclusion of the
engineers
even though our preview didn't allow us
to uncover more of their secrets
the ability to go deeper into the story
and world of aliens
pairs with a strategic focus that
broadens as you play
leveling up your marine unlocks more
gear to try allowing you to customize
your loadout
add attachments to weapons that make
them more effective and provide bonuses
that align with specific playstyles
a magazine upgrade for your pulse rifle
can increase your ammo stock for
instance
but it might also make the gun reload
faster when fully empty
or fire with more stability you can also
switch those guns out altogether
swapping your pulse rifle for a burst
rifle or your shotgun for a flamethrower
you'll need to pick which upgrades and
which weapons work best for you
and the way you play you'll also unlock
perks for your character classes as you
level them up
many of which can be mixed and matched
between those classes
to allow for even more customization
it's an expansive system
that we only saw a glimpse of but it
seems like it could potentially offer a
lot of different ways
to create your own personal marine there
are also
challenge cards you earn as you play and
use to add modifiers to missions
that sometimes make things easier but
mostly increase the difficulty
by making you take more damage
restricting your weapons killing your
motion tracker
or forcing you to hit headshots fighting
through those drawbacks earns you a big
boost to your experience point gains if
you complete a mission
coupled with the game's internal ai
which changes what kinds of enemies you
run into
and wear it's a system that seems like
it can really help vary fire team elites
missions in some big ways
all these variations are meant to give
you good reasons to replay the campaigns
in aliens fire team elite
and the question is whether the game can
keep players coming back
while fire team elite created some
really harrowing moments for our group
over several hours of play it did feel
like it fell into a bit of a repetitive
pattern of moving from place to place
and setting up defensive positions that
said
we only saw two campaigns and across
those two fire team elite provided a
bunch of different enemies and
challenges to deal with
and the story suggests that things will
only get more intense
as you go on so it'll be interesting to
see how fire team elite keeps players
engaged long
term with unlockable weapons attachments
perks and cosmetic items
there are at least a lot of ways to
continually customize your character
and things to chase along the way it
also seems like fire team elite
is in a unique position to tell an
expansive
evolving alien story through a live
service game approach
for aliens fans that's a pretty exciting
prospect
and our early look at fire team elite
suggests there's a lot
that cold iron studios can draw on to
continue to throw threats at colonial
marines
that will have them endlessly fighting
for their lives
[Music]
you